Pac-Man, Gobble the Energizers or get gobbled by ghosts.
And welcome to NEStalgia, chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
And right off the bat, we've got to discuss this chronologicalness because this is a weird time for chronological orders in NES games specifically released in North America because I'm not sure exactly where to put Pac-Man.
It had an unlicensed version.
It had a licensed version.
Namco put out an official version in 1993.
So, you know, I'm placing it here.
But for all we know, we should have played Pac-Man months ago or we're playing it too early.
Yeah. A few months ago, I played Pac-Man in preparation of one of these episodes.
And I had learned that I had played the wrong game.
So I went off after the unlicensed version, which I believe should be wrong regardless.
Yeah. Unlicensed games are illegal for what it's worth.
They are illegal.
Well, you know, that brings up a good discussion.
Are they illegal? Because Nintendo did fight this and pretty much won.
Because Tenjin is the company that made this Pac-Man game really is just a subsidiary of Atari who wanted to make this spinoff label because they were they saw a loophole in one of Nintendo's rules that basically a developer could only release a certain amount of games for the NES in a particular year.
And Atari didn't like that.
So they created Tenjin.
It's this way they could release more.
And Tenjin also saw an opportunity to just reverse engineer the lockout chip on the NES.
And so this way they could make chips without going through Nintendo's official seal and releasing them into the market.
Nintendo didn't like that one bit.
And they told Toys R Us and other game stores, like, if you sell Tenjin games, you won't be selling any official Nintendo games.
So take your pick.
That's pretty rough.
Very the man of them.
Right. We can talk about, like, whether that was cool, you know, or legal.
But we're not going to do that because we're just going to focus on Pac-Man the game here.
And before we even talk about the NES version, I just want to hear your guys, like, familiarity with Pac-Man.
Like, when do you first remember playing Pac-Man?
What does Pac-Man mean to you?
He is kind of a video game icon.
So, Joe, let's start with you.
I mean, it's hard to really remember, like, my first...
Obviously, there's so many versions of Pac-Man.
You can play Pac-Man on so many different, like, platforms.
The one that I remember the most is not by any means the classic Pac-Man, but there was...
It was on, like, my Windows computer and it was just some random program that was, like, an endless Pac-Man.
It was, like, each level was, like, five or six of these one Pac-Man screen screens.
So, when you go off to the little thing to the left or the right that usually loops you around, it would take you to another screen.
And it had, like, a jazzy music to it.
I don't think it was a very popular thing.
I just remember, like, playing that on, like, on our old, like, Windows 98 computer for a while.
But then, obviously, I've played a lot of other things.
Like, a couple years ago, somebody had, like, this...
I think it's, like, a moderately popular, like, Pac-Man game, but he had it on his Roku TV.
And I don't remember what it's called, but it was just, like, another, like, endless Pac-Man thing.
Yeah, but, you know...
Pac-Man 256, I think it was.
Yes, that's the one. Yeah, that's it.
I knew that that one was kind of recognizable, so I was hoping one of you guys would remember what it was.
Yeah, so... I remember the first time I played Super Mario.
And I remember the first time I played a lot of games from this era.
But, like, because nobody in our age bracket can seem to remember the first time they played Pac-Man,
I can only imagine that it's just you're born with the knowledge.
Because, yeah, I have no idea the first time I played this was probably when I was three or four years old.
But, no, I mean, I enjoy it.
I can't get past, like, the third level, but it's got a very satisfying quality to it.
You know, I actually can remember...
I wouldn't say, like, remember the date, but I can remember playing this on my grandmother's NES one day when we went over there.
They had Super Mario Bros., Pac-Man, and I want to say Paperboy.
And I remember playing Pac-Man, and I think what's cool about Pac-Man is that from the time I first played it until now, I haven't gotten any better.
I just... I play Pac-Man.
To Sean's point, I enjoy Pac-Man.
Pac-Man, it satisfies, and I think that that's, like, that's the universal appeal of a game like Pac-Man,
is that there are certain people who know, like, well, if you go in this exact order, if you go in this route for this map,
the ghost will never touch you, and you'll be able to eat all four of them all the time.
And it's like, that's one way to play a game.
But then there's also just, like, a satisfactory way of playing something that's just for fun,
that, like, people who never play video games will still play something like Pac-Man, Pong.
I don't know what else really fits into that category of, like, so simple that anyone can enjoy them.
But Pac-Man definitely...
Yeah, Centipede. There you go.
Again, Space Invader's probably more likely than Centipede.
Yeah, I think Pac-Man just had something about him, you know, so early on.
You know, there aren't other games like that.
Like, why have we not seen other games that just take place in, like, an enclosed maze,
and you just have to, like, traverse through it, you know?
Like, we don't... that doesn't exist as a genre.
I feel like because it's so simple that any way that you do it,
if you're going to be close enough to Pac-Man, will just look like a ripoff of Pac-Man.
You know, it's, like, such a simple gameplay style.
So you go through a maze and you collect the dots.
Then there's just something very satisfying about just systematically cleaning up this board.
Like, I think that's really what it is.
Just seeing your progress, like, very visibly on the screen is, like, what, to me, is, like, that's so satisfying.
You're just kind of, like, vacuuming up all these...
I'm making it sound really boring, but you're just, like, cleaning up this whole board, and by the end...
No, you're right. I did that.
I undid everything that was on this board.
Yeah, that... When you have that feeling of...
Yeah, I guess I can't really describe it in any other words,
but if you are...
If you have a bunch of stuff on the board and your goal is to get rid of it,
that is, in itself, a satisfying...
I don't know if it's, like, something deep in our psyche, but...
Yeah, dude, I mean, I get satisfied when I mow the lawn and I look back and I'm like,
wow, it's like I'm a short of the grasses.
I did all that. Like, that's what this is, like, scratching that same itch.
For sure. And sure, Pac-Man could get a game where he mows the lawn and that happens, you know,
but it is interesting that nobody decided to also make a game like that.
And to be clear, there are plenty of Pac-Man clones on all sorts of early consoles.
I think, like, the Atari 2600, the ColecoVision, the Intellivision,
they all had Pac-Man clones, but nothing was able to take over
what made Pac-Man such a strong game and stop its domination,
and people were really just waiting for Pac-Man to come to those consoles appropriately.
So if you had beaten Pac-Man to the Atari 2600 and created basically the same game,
it still didn't win because it wasn't Pac-Man.
I think that says something about a game like this, right?
I think so.
So, you know, we talked about that Pac-Man's enjoyable and that it satisfies,
but other than just clearing the stage, what makes the game fun to you guys?
You know, the ghosts that are chasing you, Blinky, the red one, Pinky, the pink one,
Inky, who I believe is referred to as Cyan, and Clyde, who's orange.
You know, these four ghosts that just traverse the screen,
they don't really have any rhyme or reason either.
I wouldn't say they're, like, well-programmed AI, right?
I think it's somewhere built into the code that one of them follows you,
another one roams, another one purposefully, like, dodges corners that you don't dodge.
I know there is some design logic there, but for the most part,
you're just kind of like, it's this game of tag, right?
Yeah, I mean, I wouldn't dismiss the creative AI that they put into the game outright,
because I think it is very creative the way that they made it,
so that it's not just, like, you get a conga line behind you,
because this game very easily could have fallen into that.
So that it's always just a matter of time until you're cornered.
But, yeah, I think that without that, this game would have been way too easy,
and it would not have the same legacy that it does now.
Yeah, I was going to mention, too, I actually had forgotten
until a little bit into playing this game that I had heard, you know,
in my adult life of some time that the ghost had such specific programming,
and I think that's really cool, and I'm still not familiar enough with them
to be able to, like, use that to my advantage or use that information,
but that makes me a little more interested in, like, playing more just to see,
like, if you watch someone who's, like, good at this game play it,
it looks like they do, they are aware, okay, like, Pinky's coming at me,
but I know the way Pinky moves, so I know kind of how to counter that right off the bat.
I think that's a cool thing, and it's also just a fun bit of knowledge
where I feel like not everybody knows that when they play Pac-Man,
so it's kind of a cool little Easter egg to drop on someone.
Yeah, it's a great topic for parties.
Yeah. And there's not much else going on, right?
Like, you have the power pellets, and you have the fruit
that appear in the center of the screen,
but it's not like the game gets more complicated as you go on.
If I understand correctly, it's just that the ghosts get faster,
and the time that you have between the power pellet and the ghosts...
Yeah. Like, everything gets faster.
Everything just gets faster, right.
So, what do you think about that as an approach?
Like, we always complain about, you know, games that don't have enough going on
after a certain amount of gameplay loop.
Is this simple enough that it's just fine,
and it's almost just, like, your brain...
You know, it's using, like, a separate part of your brain
that just enjoys doing this?
Yes. I personally would have liked to see, like, vastly changed layouts of the maze,
because I think another thing that makes this game fun
is that it's not just, oh my god, I gotta get all the power pellets
or whatever they're called, energy pellets or whatever,
and not get hit by the ghosts,
but it's also, like, effectively managing your route
to kind of, like, take as little time as possible,
at least for me, so you're in danger.
You know, like, I don't want to miss a bunch of dots
in the bottom left corner and have to come back to it later.
Like, I want to be able to make every, like, pass...
Yeah, you want to be efficient.
...every passage, like, capitalized.
Yeah, exactly. And I imagine that if you're playing this a lot
and you're getting really good at it
and it's always the same layout of the board,
even if it gets faster, you kind of will just have, like,
go-to strategies for every level,
and it'll stop challenging you on that level,
and then it'll just become a test of your reflexes,
and it might just lose that more cerebral aspect of it
that it would have if it was, like, a new layout every time.
You also have to remember that
not only are you getting this moment-to-moment gameplay,
and it's, you know, it's very tight in that regard,
but every couple levels you do get a slice
of the very involved story of Pac-Man.
Right, that's true.
The cutscenes are...
Some people refer to them as the first video game cutscenes.
I think they're right.
Yeah, I think it's kind of funny to call them cutscenes at all,
but it is nice that you get anything
other than just the next maze, you know?
Because technically, Joe, as we talked about earlier,
you know, the Pac-Man 256 thing,
that's alluding to the fact that there are 256 mazes,
and then you get to the kill screen,
which basically is just, like, a nonsense screen
that glitches out on you and forces the game to end.
You know, that's pretty much all Pac-Man has to offer,
is just 256 mazes as it gets faster and faster.
I'm sure there is a limit so that, like, after...
Who knows? That's legible.
Maybe even the first 20 stages,
it's like the speed just remains constant from that point on.
I am not a pro Pac-Man player and don't know.
But I think it's kind of interesting
that future Pac-Man games would try
to, like, add on to the Pac-Man formula,
and you guys have...
I guarantee you've never heard of these games.
Like, after Pac-...
Well, Mike, Mike, Mike,
before we go into, like, the...
Oh, I'm not doing sequels and spinoffs.
I'm bringing up a point here
about the simplicity of the game,
you know, and how it works in its favor,
because a lot of times we pick on simple games as, like,
yeah, I mean, all you could really do in this game
was just shoot, so that wasn't that fun.
But meanwhile, it's like, yeah,
all you can do is eat dots in this game,
but we're loving it. Yeah, but that's the difference
between simplicity and elegance,
and I think that Pac-Man is an elegant game.
I want to talk about, you know,
and this is not sequels and spinoffs,
but I want to talk about Pac-Man Plus,
Super Pac-Man, Baby Pac-Man,
Professor Pac-Man, and Pac and Pal.
These are the first arcade games
in a line of, like, who knows?
There's countless Pac-Man games.
So these are the first
in a series of Pac-Man arcade games
that I guarantee you guys have no idea
what any of those are
and what makes them different
than regular Pac-Man.
Am I right? I haven't played any of those.
Joe? Okay, yeah.
Yeah, because it's like,
it's interesting. So Pac-Man Plus is virtually
the same exact game
as regular Pac-Man,
except for that
they tweaked the graphics a little bit
so that now the maze is green
instead of blue,
and honestly, I think that's where most players,
that's where most players probably got off.
They were like, well, the screen's green.
I don't know what that's about.
Probably defective, you know?
I thought you meant they, like, got off on that.
I was like, what? Yeah.
Like, most players are like, wow, this is great.
But now there's also, like,
they added bonus items,
like a can of Coca-Cola
and stuff like that,
and eating a power pellet
sometimes has unpredictable results,
and I think that kind of stuff
in Pac-Man Plus
is what made people
not be like, oh, well, this is better
than Pac-Man in every way.
People liked playing Pac-Man.
They didn't want the changes.
Now, could you explain
what would happen
if in some instances
that you'd eat a power pellet?
So if you ate,
yeah, if you ate a power pellet,
sometimes it would turn
the maze invisible.
Oh, gee. Or it would turn
only three of the four ghosts blue.
Oh. You know?
The ghosts were also
faster and more aggressive
than they were in the original Pac-Man.
So I just think, like, that's an example of, like,
I might have wanted,
you know, like a can of Coca-Cola
in the original Pac-Man.
Seems harmless, right?
But maybe it wouldn't have sold as well.
Seems refreshing. Yeah.
Coca-Cola satisfies.
And then Baby Pac-Man,
a game that is basically Pac-Man,
but also adds a pinball machine
to the bottom of it.
Oh. Wait.
I don't understand that at all.
Yeah. Are you controlling Pac-Man
while playing pinball?
There is a joystick
and there's also flippers.
So the mechanical pinball section
operates as a traditional,
of course smaller, it's not, like, super long,
pinball machine.
And the player hits targets
with a metal ball
using the flippers.
And basically,
the things that you collect on there
don't matter at all
except for in terms of score
because play always, like,
is separated between
the top and the bottom.
So I think what happens is
that Pac-Man can go down,
or maybe it's Baby Pac-Man,
the sprite doesn't look any different,
can go down the maze
instead of just the exits on the side.
And if you go down the maze,
that's when you enter the pinball mode.
Huh. I guess I should have known
since it's called Baby Pac-Man
and it's obviously what it's going to be.
Right. Yeah. And then this one's a little more obvious,
though. You have Professor Pac-Man,
which was not released
for, like, the NES
or the Atari 2600.
It was released... It just solved equations.
...just for the arcade,
and it's just a quiz game.
It's, like, it's just Pac-Man
answering, like, which pair of sunglasses
are the same, and it shows you, like,
a graphic image of sunglasses,
and then you have to, like,
look at them and be like,
it's B. B is the same.
So, like, Pac-Man is the character you're playing.
He's, like, the star power
they put into their trivia game?
Right. Essentially, that's what it is.
People did not want this stuff, though,
because none of these sold nearly as well.
And so I think it's just funny
that we have, like,
Super Pac-Man,
where there's a power-up
where Pac-Man gets, like,
to be twice as big,
and it's, like,
now he's just overlapping the maze.
Like, there's so many things
that you can think of
to do with Pac-Man,
but at the end of the day,
you should have just stuck
with regular Pac-Man.
And it just makes me question
my own, like,
my own complaints
in earlier games
where I was like, oh, well,
they should have added this
or they should have added that.
Like, maybe they shouldn't have.
Maybe these games
are a little more well-laid out
than I think they are.
I wouldn't give any credit
to the people that we have in the past
criticized, Mike.
I think that that shows
that you are wrong on everything.
So I would just say
to counter that,
that Pac-Man,
going back to how
I think that it is
not just a simple game
but an elegant game,
it is hard to improve upon
something that is
pretty, like,
platonically idealistic,
you know? So,
whereas in another
simple game, you can improve it
by adding one feature
or another, the essence of Pac-Man
is just navigating
this maze and if you add
a bunch of random shit
like, you know, spying the difference
between pictures or adding a pinball machine
to the bottom of it,
it's not going to have
the same effect. I think that they,
they may have made
more interesting versions
of it in the future
which I'm sure we're going to go into
but their first thoughts
were not the correct thoughts.
Got it, got it.
Yeah, I think it's just
confusing to get a game
that I can't really critique,
you know? And that is because
it's just, it's so simple.
Like, I could say,
oh, maybe they should have
added more maze exits,
you know? Like, it's cool
that you can jump screen
between left and right
but that's not so useful
when you're trapped at the top or bottom
but like, I don't know if it necessarily
needed an exit
at the top or bottom.
That's also a pretty nitpicky thing, you know?
That's true. That's true too.
It's not a core
gameplay element
like a lot of the things
that we have problems with
in like prior episodes.
Right, okay, so here's another one.
Should the dots
have been on every single
square inch of the maze
or should they have
just kind of been
carefully spaced out
in pockets?
Well, I think you lose
a little bit of that satisfaction we talked
about before if it's carefully spaced out.
I don't know. I think carefully spaced out
would make you think
about how to get
to those places but when it's
covering the whole maze
anyways, you still have to get
to those places plus everywhere else.
So I'm not, I don't know,
I kind of like, I like the way it is.
Okay, and then
how about,
you know, this is just me trying.
These aren't valid things.
These are me throwing
things out into the wind
to try and find
a fault with Pac-Man.
Should it have been
that if you eat a ghost
and then he goes
to the jail, right?
I'm assuming that center thing is like jail.
Should it have been
that he's able to come
right back out
while you're still powerful
but meanwhile he's not blue?
Like, why was he afraid of you
when you had the power pellet
but then you eat him,
he goes back to the jail
and comes right out
while you're still powerful
and he says,
this time I'm not afraid.
See, I would say
that, like sort of countering
the entire concept
of this argument, that when you eat a ghost
you should be able to become a ghost
and then chase
another Pac-Man.
But I don't think
of these as like real ghosts.
Yeah, they're definitely
wearing some kind of canvas.
No, I think of these as real ghosts.
No, because like they
Like old family members?
These are dead people. No,
they cannot be,
yeah, they can't be
because I think,
no, I think these ghosts
have like
an actual physicality
to them because they touch you
and you die.
You touch them when you're powerful
and they go to jail
at least so that means something,
you know? I think that like
just because like when you touch them
you die it doesn't mean
that they have any like matter to them.
Like it's not like they're a solid object
it's just that they're stealing your Pac-essence.
You think they shocked him
maybe? Like they scared him
and that's why he like
makes that shrieking sound
like they're No,
I think they're
generally taking his life force
and then he crumples up
into his constituent
biological parts
on the floor
and that's what that is.
So, I don't think
that they have to be physical
to turn
to turn Pac-Man
into a pirate
style of viscera. I don't think
that's the case. But now that you mention it
when I was younger I actually did not
it never dawned on me
that they were ghosts like when I first saw this
they look like I always thought they were
like some little tentacly creatures
like aliens or something
like yeah something like that
but now I've just
I'm just so it's so ingrained to me
that they're ghosts that I've actually forgotten
that I didn't believe
that they were ghosts
at the beginning. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You've unlocked like repressed memories.
Well, you know if you watch
any of the Pac-Man TV shows
you know
you'd probably learn a lot of the lore
to each of these
these ghost characters
and you know
maybe like who they
used to be before they died
and stuff. I think Pinky and Clyde
were married at one point.
I'm not sure. Yeah, and apparently
Inky is often depicted
as a goofy
and slow-headed ghost.
Oh, that's just unfair.
Yeah, I don't I don't like that
characterization. Yeah, and I mean
like I could joke
with you right now and actually look up
like deep lore
for Pac-Man like the fact that
Inky's home is Ghostland
but honestly
this whole thing is just like
mumbo jumbo to me
like it's crazy
that there are games
like Pac and Roll
and Pac-Land
that I've never heard of
that like have
have additional information
on Pac-Man for me.
Well, Mike
you were trying
to find a critique on the game
so can I give you
a critique that I have
particularly about
the NES version?
Oh, this would be great
because you need a reason
not to try it on. That's what we're talking about.
Yeah, we do.
So like I said
I've played this in many other versions
and I'm sure everybody's
played this in tons of different versions
and the biggest thing
I noticed in the NES version
is that the turn controls
are like a little unresponsive
or maybe they're so precise
that like I feel like
I miss turns quite a bit
like you can't just
like press the button and hold it to turn
or like even for a second
you have to like do like a sharp tap
at the exact moment.
I don't know if you guys had that experience
but I noticed
I miss turns a lot
where I'm like I definitely hit the button
but I must have timed it
like poorly
like the timing must just be so precise.
Did you guys notice that?
Well, here's the thing, Joe.
I'm a sucker for turns in Pac-Man.
Like that's my favorite thing
to do in Pac-Man
is to anticipate
my next move.
But of all the other things
to do in Pac-Man?
No, that's my favorite
and so what's interesting
is like in the arcade version
it's very clear
and I don't know if it's just because
the screen's bigger
or what have you but if you
can only turn left or right
as you're like moving up the maze, right?
If you hold down
like left as your option
it will register that
and automatically move you left
even if there's nowhere
to move left yet.
Like when you get to the point
where you can move between left and right
it will register that
and move you left
and that's what I really like
about games like
Pac-Man Championship Edition
and Miss Pac-Man
and stuff like that. I just couldn't pull it off
in this game and I wasn't sure
if it was just that I didn't give it enough
like if there wasn't enough room
between the barriers
for that to happen
like that the open spaces
were just always right around the corner
but I couldn't pull it off
in the sense that like if I tap left
and then don't have it
pre-registered
like holding it down
if it would go left or not
and so I would say
that like that matters
like it's kind of important
because being able to plot out your moves
is what matters most
in a game like Pac-Man right?
Yeah yeah and I feel like
in most games like this
this is going to sound
like a weird nitpick
but when you're actually playing it
I feel like it's pretty noticeable
but like in other games
you'll kind of like
hold the D-pad
and like kind of roll your thumb
to the next you know to the next
you know to the right
of the D-pad if you were on the up
now I feel like you have to just do
like a quick tap at the exact moment
and I feel like
that was what was
making me miss turns
like if I were to just kind of roll my thumb
to the other side
of the D-pad he just wouldn't respond
Yeah I don't I can't say that
I had the same experience
I thought that
I was alright
with like pre-loading
my input I still miss turns
but that's just I blame myself
in terms of like
my reaction time
but I guess I don't
have anything else
to say on that topic
Yeah it just
overall like
just to sum it up
it felt harder
to control than other versions
of Pac-Man that I've played
And I would argue
that like for me
I prefer to play
Pac-Man on
you know on a D-pad
as opposed to
a joystick I know that sounds
kind of crazy but I like it
when I'm purposefully
pushing if there's only
four directions to go anyway
I like it when I'm purposefully
toggling the direction
I want on something
like a D-pad or a keyboard
than a joystick
which technically can you know
rotate a full
360 degrees
Yeah I think
I would agree if there's
only four points
then might as well
cut out any of the
extra distraction there
Not that it would
register a
diagonal movement
anyway it's just that
I prefer to feel precise
in my movements as Pac-Man
And did anybody
even bother to collect the fruit?
Like do you guys
care about
stuff like that? Like for us
high score doesn't matter
so like when you saw
the fruit in the center
were you like yeah I'll just
stop collecting the dots
for a second and go get the fruit?
I would try
and loop back around and grab it
if it was if an opportunity
presented itself but
it was never
my number one concern
but I still had
that subconscious
want Yeah I think it's fun
right? It's like there's something about the fruit
that's just fun to eat
it's like the whole game
is about eating
so it might as well
Right and it's nice to see
yeah it's nice to see
the fruit that you've
collected like on the side
the whole time so you can get just like
it's like your little trophies
so like I actually also
went for it You're on your way to a picnic
Yeah exactly
I think that's the end goal
of this game
I also this is just like
a real non sequitur
but I always thought
that like the dots
looked like little
like what are those tiny little like
pasta balls and I always thought
like those looked good
too like oh like eating pasta
no no
those tiny the little like
the tiny little like little
spheres they're like tiny
and they're little
is the only way of describing it
Yeah they're tiny and they're little
I know exactly Also is it
pretty much like
Pac-Man though right
they just look like
Pac-Man if he just
closed his mouth
True Yeah like baby Pac-Man
got smaller Maybe he's like
like those crabs
that eat the
the baby crabs
you know like they just like
they give birth to them
and then just immediately start eating them
maybe that's what Pac-Man does
Yes
and for the record
I'm thinking of whatever the
the pasta is in
like Italian wedding soup
those tiny little like dots
Ah minestrone
No
Oh I honestly don't know
I thought you were
talking about the little meatballs
in Italian wedding soup
for a second I was like
that's not a pasta
I'll find the name of it
Anyway to get away from
pasta for a second
did you guys know Pac-Man was originally
called Puck-Man
Yes
Okay and do you think
that that was a good
decision to change
his name I guess it's
corruptible I think the reason
was because of
graffiti Yes
or vandalism
Vandalism
You know I actually
don't know
what a Pac-Man is
you know like Puck-Man does sound
like the better way to describe him
but
you know
at the point that I was alive
it just felt right
to call him Pac-Man
it was like you know
it's like yeah everybody's
going along with it we'll call him Pac-Man
You're born with the knowledge
Right It's just something
you cannot you cannot dispute
Yes exactly
and that's how that's my feelings
towards Pac-Man is like
if I see him
even though
at one point it might have made sense
to call him Puck-Man
I don't feel like
that's correct It's like
I you know my mom told me
that at a certain point
they were thinking
name me Vince but I'm not Vince
I'm Sean Right
so But you do look like a Vince
You know
and Mike you kind of look like a Pete
Oh no
that's no good
Oh no You know
we really didn't talk about
our strategies
for playing this game
and I know that it's pretty simple
and we've covered that
gambit of it but I wonder about
for the ghosts
and stuff like that
and the power pellets
did you guys
try to eat
all four all four ghosts
when you got the power pellets
did you use that as an opportunity
to just like
eat more pellets
on the screen while they stayed away from you
Joe I'm curious to hear what you did
I well I used the
the big power pellets
as like I tried to spare them
to keep them
as like a defense if suddenly
I felt like I was being chased
I could go to the nearest
power pellet
and turn the
put the ghosts on the defense
and I would try to eat the ghosts
if they were within reasonable range
but then I watched
a lot of like plays on YouTube
also and it looks like
like the people who are really good
of the game will try and eat
all the ghosts because they're trying
to rack up their score
but for me it was more of just
a way to get them off my tail
for a minute so I can continue
trying to clear the level
yeah I would I would say that
I was sort of in the middle there
that I would
hold off for a bit
to see if I could get them close
because it is a very satisfying
crunch whenever you get
to them and especially
when they're all lined up
for you but at a certain
point like you're not
just gonna leave the power pellet
and then everything else around it
empty for you to have to come
back and clear so
it's just whatever situation
I was in yeah I found
myself actually
you know if I wasn't
in any immediate danger
I would just
lock my Pac-Man
to whatever
direction would keep him
up against the side of the wall
and wait for the
ghosts to come
near me so that this way
I could then like as soon as
they got close enough eat the power
pellet and eat some
of them and continue
to clear the
rest of the stage so this way
I was making like kind of
progress on both
but focusing on the points
so you were
camping I was camping
yes and I'm pretty
sure that you know
that's illegal in video games
you can't camp
yep so I don't
know how to play video games
correctly apparently
but I would
say that that is a legitimate
strategy for
everyone it's the best
of both worlds in my opinion
because you
can eat the ghosts that
try to attack
you when they know full well
that there's a power pellet right
around the corner and then at the
same time you don't have to
chase the other ones that didn't
take the bait because they were
smart enough and chances are
they're also smart
enough to know what to do in
the situation of a power pellet
the amount of anthropization that
you have for these anthropomorph
positions I did very
fine well don't
worry it's fine
because we found out too
that Inky is
actually a chef
in the second
cutscene of
Pac-Man world
so he's
scolded by Toc-Man for
not making his cake chocolate
so these things all
happen and there is lore
and there is a
universe established
it's all behind the scenes
right it's for the
real nitty gritty stuff
Pac-Man you know
is a thing
that has like there's a song
about him there's like
graffiti for
Pac-Man all over
the world right
like that's just something
it's iconic
now at this point to
associate Pac-Man imagery
with gamers
and yet
there's nothing really toxic
about Pac-Man
right I thought that
Pac-Man was a little racist
at some point but I do
agree that now
he's cleaned up his act
okay that's good
that's good and so
you know I would like to
just walk through
some of the sequels and
spinoffs because there's
a few that we have to talk
about and the most
important one I think is
Miss Pac-Man
which is the
direct follow-up
to Pac-Man and was the
most successful Pac-Man game
in North America in the arcades
for some reason
it sold more
units than regular Pac-Man
I'm not sure
if that's because they made
Miss Pac-Man
sexy or you know
because they
made her like a Marilyn Monroe
character I'd say that
in addition to that it was
also because the cut scenes
were much more
high quality like you get
to watch
a love story
unfold yeah they were
like titled right
yeah yeah they were
titled it was like they meet
they kiss
like I remember
that yeah so that happens
and that's probably
the first narrative
in video games
yeah it was really
really like you're
playing that little story narrative
by every level
you defeat it's like
it's a Quantic Dream
I think developed I think it's just
important to like
for Miss Pac-Man
you know for Pac-Man
they do
you know
make him into
into a character
with legs
and arms
and stuff like that and then they go
as far as to explain that like
Pac-Man had legs
even in the original
Pac-Man game
he was just wearing rollerblades
so that's how he grew so fast
wait so are we looking at him
top down so his mouth
opens like sideways
no that's impossible
I think they just
didn't have the memory
you know you have to use your imagination
right okay
but yeah
for certain things you don't have
to imagine how he walked
they'll explain that it was
rollerblades but you should
know that
that his mouth
doesn't open sideways
but yeah
Miss Pac-Man it's weird
because then they show her
legs but they make
them like they make
them like photorealistic
women's legs
and stuff like
very curvy
and things and I'm like
why like that
that just seems so unnecessary
but were they
photorealistic was it like
a real like image of legs
no that's terrifying
he's just saying that
they're drawn a little bit
more realistic yeah they're
drawn more realist than
say yeah
exactly yeah I
don't know it's like Betty Boop's
legs but with
Miss Pac-Man's
body it's very
strange anyway
and then there
are many bad Pac-Man
games that we just
can't cover here there's too
many of them but then
there's the Pac-World
games are you guys
familiar with the Pac-Man
world games no
are these the like the
the modern
arcade titles they're the
3D platformers
on the PlayStation 1
and PlayStation 2
and
and I think
they might have gotten their way
to the GameCube as well
and stuff like that I think it
was I think they were called Pac-World
but I played
this Pac-World
1 at least
growing up on PlayStation 1
I played that game
and I remember
because I had already played
Super Mario 64
and
Sonic Adventure
that my
understanding as a
kid was just like well of
course this is where Pac-Man
needs to go
you know like he needs to
go to 3D
and become a platformer just
like Sonic did
and just like Mario showed
off how you can make the jump
from 2D to 3D
but now of
course I look at these games
and they're garbage so I kind
of wonder like did Pac-
was Pac-Man just best left
at like this
very first game
that just happens to be pretty
close to perfection
I think so
I think that the only thing
that personally
that I think you could improve
upon is by taking this
formula and
changing things like keeping it
within the formula
changing the layout of the
maze maybe playing
around with like having
dots placed not everywhere
or different ways you have
to get there but like nothing
I don't think
it needs fancy power
ups or weird things that the
that the power pellets do when
you eat them I think just
having new
challenges in
the layout and keeping
the sentiment
the same I think that's
I mean this game
is just so simple I think that's
all it needs you know Joe
I got great news for you
it's a game
called Pac-Man
Championship Edition!
DX it
was on my top
five games of
the decade for the 2010s if
you remember that episode where
we recorded that and that's exactly
what they did to finally set
Pac-Man it's very
enjoyable in a
multiplayer setting
in the arcades
and I think
there's just something about
how it took
them 30
plus years
to get to the
point where they just say oh
well what if we
just took the original formula
and you know
I don't want to say it's like a
rhythm game or
something like that but there is like
a flow state
to the game where the dots
are placed you know
they're placed
purposefully so that you
can perfectly capture ghosts
along your
route and then
as soon as you finish
that route of doing it
correctly a new route
is placed where you
catch even more ghosts
and then eventually it
leads to a power pellet
where you can eat like 60
ghosts at a time
all set to music
it's super
satisfying it's an
amazing game
and I think
that's what's crazy is like
they tried to add things
to the original Pac-Man
they tried to go away from
that and turn Pac-Man into
you know
everything from a quiz show
to a 3D
platformer
to Tetris
games they made
Pac-Attack
which was a Tetris game
you know they tried
all those different things
and it's
amazing because the brand was
still just fine
because people still enjoy
that regular Pac-Man
just a-okay
that when Pac-Man
Championship Edition came out
people were
like whoa what's this
finally like a
creative new spin
on the
formula that worked way
back in 1980
but where do Pac-Man
games go from here
VR but you know
you joke Sean but I
was thinking and this is
this is serious
so even though it sounds crazy
remember
the Budweiser
commercial where they
like turned Pac-Man
into like
real life and they had a guy
like run through
a real life
maze of Pac-Man
I know
but I
I'm interested
yeah it
definitely it was like a Super Bowl
commercial and they used it
for like two years straight
not at the Super Bowl
but like afterwards
it was just all over the
place in terms of commercials
and I do
wonder if like Pac-Man
in VR
where you
are like you know
first person running through
these mazes collecting the
dots and you
can't see the ghosts
on the screen
you just kind of like as
you turn the corners
you see them I could
imagine that turning
into a little bit of like a survival
horror style
thing it could
it may well exist
already in Alien Isolation
but like
if you take it as a
Pac-Man game I think
Pac-Man could do well
in VR in that
regard of like
a new element
of surprise for
Pac-Man players
I could
do it yeah you would
just have to do something
to make it not
impossible like you'd
have to slow the ghosts down
or make it so you could see
them coming a little further
ahead otherwise you would
just turn corners into ghosts
all the time I think
it would be great
and it would look great
on like
the PS5
when it comes out if it
was just people with
sheets over
their head right
that's true too
I mean you know
if we want to just rip off
directly from Pac-Man
Verse which
was a crazy complicated
to play GameCube game
that required three Game Boy
Advances as
well if you want
to use that as an idea
the way that
worked is Pac-Man
could be controlled by
a GameCube controller
and then
if three
Game Boy Advances
using the
Game Boy Advance to
GameCube connector
were plugged into the
GameCube as well
they could
control the ghosts on
their Game Boy Advances
so this way
it was three
people as the ghosts and
one person as Pac-Man
and that
made it for like a fun
thing where like no longer
do you have to rely on the
AI it's people
chasing it's your friends chasing
you down I think that
could work well in VR
too where like the
ghosts are other VR
players so it's like nobody
has any idea
where they're going the real
monsters are other people
right and
that's why they wear sheets
to reveal
themselves at the end it's
like you pull off the sheet
and you see your friends
and you're like oh you
but I
yeah I think that's where Pac-Man
goes from here if we're being
honest I'm
glad we kind of came to
that conclusion Sean together
but I
can't really see you know
because they did do Pac-Man
Championship Edition
2 and it
just didn't have the same type
of magic because
again they tried to add
more things rather than
just create
new layouts of interesting
solves yeah I'm
watching it now
and it's just a little
it's a little chaotic
so I'm not really sure
exactly it
has that Pac-Man plus problem
yeah yeah so I
think I think if you want to
do it you got to look at
the 1980 game and
use new technology
to make it fun again
but that's it for Pac-Man
talk you know
we could have
done a whole lot of things on
development but I don't think
it's worth it because Pac-Man
on the NES was developed
by a bunch of people who
were hell-bent on selling
unlicensed video games
yeah they do
not deserve to be talked
about right it is worth
noting in terms of like why
does the game play pretty well
if it's unlicensed
or if it is licensed it
doesn't matter which version
you have it's because
it's actually all based
off of Namco's
official Famicom
version of Pac-Man
which came out in 1984
so it took
four years to get here
Namco's already
made it but they're not
releasing it
in North America
so instead Tenjin decides
like we'll
just take this
and release it
under some
like shady deals
and stuff like that which is
only going to get stranger
because Namco
is then in 1993 going to
decide like well nobody can
buy Pac-Man because Tenjin's
not allowed to sell it so
we might as
well release it again so we're
going to do all this Pac-Man talk
again in like 2028
okay I mean
that's enough time I think
yep uh okay
so let's do
the essential games list
Joe well I'm gonna
almost repeat myself from
last week although this
game I enjoyed quite
a bit and I think it's
it's got a level of
simplicity and uh
simplicity and and
just straightforward
fun where
you're just it's it's
satisfying in a
way where I think it's a play it
um but
it's also
gonna repeat Sean from
last week you've all
played this you all know
what it is um it's a
fun little look into
like old
like an old
game and like into
history uh it's not
gonna blow your
socks off or anything you know
it's exactly what Pac-Man
always has been
so I'm gonna
say it's a play it
because I think for
an arcade
game to keep my
attention this way is
nothing to uh is
nothing to uh sneeze
at but uh
but you know
it still doesn't
do anything with where I'm
itching to go back to it
yeah okay
no Sean's gonna go okay
okay no no
it's all right Michael go
no yeah
Joe would you
mind voting for me yeah I'm
gonna repeat myself from a
minute ago yeah I would
say that
Pac-Man is
as we've only
referred to so far for I
believe Donkey Kong Pac-Man is
an essential arcade game
it's one of
the few video games everyone
in the world
should play like it's so
accessible that I
can't imagine like a language
barrier being a
problem like everyone should
play Pac-Man
and the fact of
the matter is is that you
can play Pac-Man
in an arcade
still today like
it's one of the
few arcade machines that you can find
almost anywhere you can play Pac-Man
on the computer
you can probably play it if you
type in Pac-Man
on Google I'm sure you can play
that Google version
of Pac-Man you
can play Pac-Man anywhere so I
don't think this NES version is
anything to rave about
and so it'd be
really weird to have it on games
you must play on
the NES because
you can play this game anywhere so
even though I would have
considered it as
an essential game just because of
the legacy status
of it and how good it actually
still is today
it's not going to
be on our NES
essential games list because there's
nothing that makes the NES version
special I say
whenever you can
play Pac-Man even if it's just
for a minute or two you should be
playing it so go
for it Sean
yeah you've
pretty much covered everything so I'm
just going to echo
that pretend I said
everything Mike said
that's why I ran in
Sean that's why I
made sure that I
could vote second for sure
you just steal thunder
don't worry Sean
you'll have plenty to
say in your essential games vote next week
when we cover
racket attack
I know that you
have been looking forward to that one
so we're going to let you kick off the
essential games list
vote for racket attack
next week okay
yeah I think it's a
tennis game just if I had to
take a guess I'm not
it could be a
fly swatting game
I have
I have had many thoughts about
fly swatting in the
past so yeah
I mean there's a
great fly swatting
game in Mario Paint
on the Super Nintendo
so it can happen
right here in your
backyard I think you know
everybody should
play Pac-Man
today
if you listen to
this episode and you didn't even
get an itch to just
like try the
free version of
Pac-Man that you can clearly find by
googling it like I feel like
any version of
Java had this
you know it's so accessible
of a game that it makes me
think like what else is like
that like Mario
is locked behind Nintendo
so you can't just type in
Super Mario
Brothers and play it right
in your browser without doing
like some
shady sites
or you know
consciously doing
something wrong but Pac-Man
Emulation is illegal
yeah Pac-Man
you can play
emulation is only
illegal if you don't own
the game you're
emulating yeah
but you know Pac-Man is
something that you do have
access to it's almost
like a good that's
available to everybody
it's like air
yeah it's like the library
yeah Pac-Man
Pac-Man
Pac-Man and
Tetris are like the library
right you can play
it on anywhere to play some
Pac-Man right now
or just mow
the lawn yep
or mow the lawn
yeah mowing the
lawn is like playing Pac-Man
you heard it here first
Joe any
other words of encouragement
I think I
don't want to dole them all
out too quickly so maybe next
week okay that
sounds good Sean anything
else you want to say to the
listeners I actually
don't have any more words in
my vocabulary I thought you
were just gonna not say anything
to that question
yeah that would
be fun I will say that
if you enjoyed
this week's episode or any of the
episodes that we've ever done
we'd love to hear
about it you can tweet us
at NostalgiaCast
on Twitter we're very active
there I think I
posted a lot of
weird Pac-Man stuff and some
vintage Puckman
stuff I think Pac-Man
went through a
lot of different design phases
but it's important to know that
he does wear a
hat oh I wasn't
aware of that Pac-Man wears a
hat through most
of the 80s and
the early 90s
and if you didn't
know that you're
just not a Pac-Man fan because it's
the same hat every
time too so I think it's a
red trilby is what
I want to call it wow I didn't know
that Pac-Man was
like a neck beard
yes in a way
in a way
I'm Mike Esposito
you can find me at Esposito Film
on Twitter and I'll talk to
you soon I'll talk toκεκε
I'll talk toκε I'll
toκεκεκεκεκε!!!!!κεκε!!
!κεκεκεκε!!! Thank you.